welcome everyone to our second meeting
of this afternoon now we have cabinets
and apologies for absence apologies from
councillor Perry fine thank you I'm
disposed of interest I will take that as
an enthusiastic no minutes confirm
inside the minutes of the meeting on the
8th of July
agreed yep good
in that case I'll sign the minutes
moving on swiftly the gender item for
insurance contract so Chancellor Harvey
Thank You leader this paper is presented
out of necessity
the council's current provider of
insurance cover in relation to property
money business interruption and computer
risks Tokyo Marine kiln has decided to
withdraw from the UK market in the
council's case it's policy expires at
the end of November 2019
cochlear marine kiln has agreed to
extend the cover for a further two
months to facilitate the tendering
process for an alternate provider
current preman charge for the cover of
these risks is of the order of 80,000
pounds the paper seeks the cabinet's
authority for the tendering process to
be undertaken for a contract to be
awarded for a period of two years and
ten months and for the decision to award
this contract to be delegated under
contract standing orders to the interim
head of service financial services in
Section one five one officer in
consultation with the portfolio holder
financial assets and the council's
monitoring officer the criteria to be
used in evaluating those tenders are set
out in Appendix one I asked their four
recommendations one two and three set
out in the summary of this paper are
approved by the Cabinet any questions
any discussion
so the reality is we've got no choice
but to do this so basically can I have
your agreement to the recommendations on
page nine good thank you cabinets in
that kit capital budget monitoring
councillor Harvey again the purpose of
that kind introduction the purpose of
the paper is to keep members informed of
the progress made over the past four
months of the year in undertaking the
council's intended level of capital
expenditure this year table 1 on page 15
demonstrates the intention to undertake
a spend X expenditure 6.8 million pounds
this year including section 106 projects
which taking into account
additional funds of 3.6 million budgeted
this year will result in the balance of
the council's accumulated capital
receipts and grants being reduced over
the year from 5.5 million to 2.3 million
pounds
paragraph 1.5 indicates that capital
expenditure of 187 thousand pounds has
been committed and 50 thousand pounds
already undertaken by the end of July
the total of committed and undertaken
expenditure in the first four months of
the year that is 237,000 pounds
represents three and a half percent of
this year's available budget as set out
in paragraph 2 of Appendix two that
provides summary information concerning
the various projects yet to be funded
through section 106 agreements which
totaled 2.9 million pounds at the end of
July 1919 as recorded on page 29 in
addition to the 260 thousand pounds
already committed as shown on the
penultimate line on page 31 members note
the current position and receive the
report
any questions any comments councillor
Richards and take it yeah this isn't
from me this isn't this was Rosalie over
you in scrutiny by cancer Kepler hoping
you'd be here today but obviously is not
I think there were some issues raised up
covering fields of this item or the next
one but I assume they've been addressed
it would be remiss of me not to bring it
up given he's not here is it the next
one and you further questions comments
just just to have reassurance that you
know there is an enormous amount of
money tied up in section 106 and eighths
to be fought for which it to be
delivered we are sure that we will be
able to meet those delivery dates
clarity officers please we certainly
will endeavor to endeavor to do that but
and we definitely don't I think that is
absolutely right we don't want to hand
anything back so recommendation on page
15 this is just to note I believe so no
further issues identified so are we
happy to accept this paper good grade
thank you
revenue budget monitoring councillor
Harvey once again thank you leader the
purpose of this report is to inform the
cabinet of the revenue picture of the
council's finances to the end of july
2019 at the outset I need to draw the
cabinet's attention to two minor errors
in the paper first members will have
noted to the content of paragraph three
point one point two inadvertently being
repeated in the subsequent paragraph
second
the first bullet point of paragraph
three point one point four makes
reference to an unfavorable variance in
relation to housing of 36 thousand nine
hundred pounds as members will have
spotted on page thirty nine already
however the corresponding unfavorable
variance shown four lines from the foot
of page 39 under this heading is in fact
twenty-six thousand nine hundred pounds
this latter figure is the correct figure
and I'd like to presentational errors
about to begin by asking members to turn
to Appendix three on page 43 this shows
the net budget to be financed by the
council this year is eighteen point four
million pounds if we can now turn to
appendix 2 on page 41 we can see that
the budget for the whole year is the
total expenditure of 55 point 1 million
pounds from total income from various
sources of thirty-six point six million
the difference between these two numbers
of eighteen point four million
represents the total amount to be funded
from various sources asserted at the
foot of the appendix turning to the
position at the end of period four we
can see on page 41 but in round terms
the council's expenditure of nineteen
point 1 million pounds was nine hundred
thousand pounds less than budgeted
whilst it's income of eleven point eight
million pounds was also less than that
budgeted of twelve point eight million
pounds the combination of these results
is that the shortfall in income of nine
hundred forty thousand pounds at the end
of July exceeded the shortfall of eight
hundred and seventy thousand pounds at
expenditure by seventy nine thousand
pounds these results are very largely
influenced by the variances in the
administration of housing benefits
members will have noted that the largest
individual variance was an unfavorable
variance see line four
in the table on page 40 above 250 4000
pounds under this heading I repeat the
point I made at our meeting in July that
the key point in understanding the
reasons for the variations under various
headings is the degree to which the
council and its officers are able to
control the level of income and
expenditure and degree to which they are
dependent upon for example market
conditions or other agency partners as
paragraph 2 point 1 indicates it is
currently projected that at the end of
the year there will be an unfavorable
variance against the net budget of 288
thousand pounds on this basis it is
currently projected that the council's
general reserve account at the end of
the year will have declined as set out
in paragraph 6 and page 36 from 11.6
million pounds to 9.2 million pounds for
the reasons set out in the paper finally
I should like to make members aware that
the way in which this report might be
presented in future is something under
discussion with members of the
management team it's anticipated that
changes will be discussed aimed at
making it easier for members to focus on
significant changes and trends in the
council's patterns of income and
expenditure subject to questions
received any questions any comments
right obviously counselor kettle had
raised some issues I think you've
addressed all of them in there I cut
there was one I'm not I can't read what
it was but I think you've addressed it
so I just thank you on behalf of
Costigan in that case are we happy to
accept the recommendation on page 33
great Thank You members of cabinet in
that case we move on to the on block
items there are no issues arising from
over the in scrutiny so strategic policy
Advisory Group minutes from the meeting
fourth-of-july member development
working group minutes from the meeting
held on 1st of August and the market
forum stratford-on-avon
minutes of the meeting held on the
fourth of July so those are dealt with
any other matters any urgent business
there be no urgent business I declare
the meeting closed